[Music]
stop the music music is the king of
everything because I like goth the
spirit of art so I think musically I
think it's important for me to figure it
out how it sounds what is the Beats word
to cut where the drums come where the
solo comes and and I think if you have
that at least for me it's crucial hola
my name is Alejandro Gonzalez is
[Music]
revenant
[Music]
afraid
who knows how far I came from
same as that elk when they get afraid
they run deep into the woods I prepared
that film in 2011 I start scouting and
and guarding and storyboarding and start
working with visual effects and I was
very excited about the experience to to
allow myself to go to the nature and
then I realized that there is no that
kind of romantic thing of losing
yourself in nature no it's a war
you are during war with nature to make
it to work what you need you know
Leonardo he knew what how difficult it
would be physically and the commitment
to live living in Calgary for six months
and to go through all that physical
thing I took him a little bit for him to
really jump in once he jumped in it was
the best collaborator that I could have
the most Brave and passionate and
perfectionist and he understands
filmmaking he has worked with great
directors and so he has been so long
since he was 17 years that he understand
the whole Jamba love the conditions were
massive so you need a special wardrobe
you need ridiculously you know this wolf
and carpet for the feet of every horse
so the horse were completely warm and
nice and all we all were suffering but
the animal guys were taking care of that
every single horse has almost sucks you
know what I mean
the first bottle the physical scenes
that he went through were extremely
precise physically and actually
dangerous because if you do a bad move
the choreography with this kind of
stunts
and when you are doing battles with such
a speed and camera movements are so
precise again this is not cut cut there
are not pieces these are long pieces of
seven minutes with running exploring
choking this that that that it's it it
you put yourself at risk and sometimes
people get a little crazy in the films
and sometimes stunts or people like it
can go wrong very easily and I never see
him afraid or complaining or afraid of
all these horses passing very close to
me or this powder is exploding or this
guy is very tough he actually was
embracing the moment and allowing
himself to be exposed
and perfectly in time and with
truthfulness in his eyes and emotion
which is not easy he was not about me me
me me what about me he didn't care he
would like seeing the whole thing that's
what I'm saying he's a filmmaker that
understand that that that that that it's
everybody is just a piece of something
that is bigger than any of us you know
so that was grateful
Birdman
we were the real thing Reagan
we had it all
we gave it away
breathing in
we handed these posers the keys to the
kingdom breathing out you listening
really I shot that film in 19 days less
than four weeks and it was crazy kitten
was kind of the the first thing and
obvious because obviously I love Michael
Keaton I think he's an amazing actor and
then as a person I was able to meet him
and he's even the beautiful human being
but I think obviously there was some
resonance about what happened to him and
the Batman thing there were similarities
let's believe it was not about Michael
Keaton but it's about actors that's only
getting to and swallowing to the kind of
uh Universe of super murals and then
they regret or they are completely
transforming their perception and it's
hard to get back to be like uh you know
like a prestigious actor of theater in
New York Edward Norton is a you know
great theater actor in New York he
wanted to make this character so well
because he told Alejandro I know this
guy
just
stay with me yeah I'm the wrong person
to ask you he says but what is that
what's the intention in that is he fed
up with the subject so he's changing it
is he deflecting guilt over the marriage
and here's the thing you've got four
lines after that that all say the same
thing I didn't even know the man I I
only heard his name mentioned in passing
I think it was the first time in my life
where I was in a set and I couldn't stop
laughing because I mean I was ruining
scenes because I was like because these
guys make me laugh so much and I enjoyed
so much but there was a moment that I
was re we were rehearsing the scene
where For the First Time Michael invited
Edward as a character and then he said
what about did we do that and they are
going around the little table and he's
trying to direct him and to propose and
obviously this prick uh that ever Norton
character is saying what about that and
he start to manipulate the director you
know
and we were doing that and I was as a
director telling them what I needed or
what I thought was good what about did
we do that the camera would and then
Edward was taking me what about the
wizard of that whatever anyway after 70
times that he was trying to tell me what
I should do I started laughing I said do
you know what's happening what
you were exactly doing what the
character is doing and so he realized
that we started laughing about how a
mirror in a mirror in a mirror we were
playing there it was so fun the reason I
think I got into this different kind of
approach or design
of making films was because I need
sometimes the restrictions and
limitations are your best at least
creatively so I was so reducing money I
didn't have enough money I didn't have
enough time
the San James Theater rule only allow us
to [ __ ] to shoot for five days because
they are always book all year for years
but there was a coincidence that just a
theater theater played through the other
was like a five days hiatus or we have
this open thing cheap and I rehearse
every movement every step every Rhythm
the even the measures of the walls
everything the the light study where the
window will be all the needs and so the
the stage all the bagels of the of the
theater were designed and built outside
New York but when he comes out of the
time uh Times Square there was no way to
design or I have money for very extras
and that's it and I could not close
Times Square I need to shoot it with
people and not in a you know not at 3am
and one day Chi when I were walking to
have breakfast on Saturday and I saw
this military band of these kids playing
super cool with some cool dance and
everybody was watching them because it
was very noisy and cool Rhythm and I got
this idea said this is exactly what we
need we need something to distract the
tourist you know in in Times Square and
let's just get there and then while they
are watching these kids we will be
walking with this guy
forever
[Music]
and it'd work I don't know how it worked
because I thought it would be Michael
Keaton in underwear it will be 1 000
people looking to the camera and saying
stupid things and everybody got seen
this kit and if you see the film
it's exactly that we just have 30 extras
and we distract them with like like bees
with honey
while we were getting away with murder
the people say why why is in one shot
and it was because obviously because
this is again happening in in the
consciousness of a person dealing with
his own ego and he's super eagle and I
want the audience to be in a radical
point of view and to leave exactly what
he was going through and then the re
because I will not have editing
uh and a comedy is made of editing I
needed something to guide me again music
and Rhythm and I invite Antonio Sanchez
I'm a huge fan of Pat Metheny the
musician we became friends Antonio a
Mexican drummer has been his drummer for
many years and I said what about if you
just start getting and I have some ideas
and I knew the sequences so he and I got
into a studio in New York like three
weeks before start shooting and I was
describing to him the images like the
sequence in this one is a little soft
and this one is a little emotional this
one is very hard and he was just
improvising Jazzy
and before start shooting I got a lot of
tracks that informed me during the
things about that and it was kind of
pre-editing element for me to be getting
and the actors getting the Rhythm and
the vibe
babble
Babble was about these four stories of
characters that will never be they will
never been physically in the same place
they will probably will never know each
other existence but no matter how
whatever actions they are doing at that
time it will change and affect the life
of each of all the other three of her
characters they didn't know which is
kind of the butterfly kind of theory so
that was an extreme kind of exercise
with no physicality differently from
Amorous person 21 Grams and about the
impossibility of communication right and
that's why the Bible title came like
like it's a is a tower of rival as this
punishment that we got and I think we
are leaving now I think the internet
could be kind of that that we are
supposedly connected but we speak
different language and we think that we
are speaking we are completely
disassociated half of that film was shot
in Moroccan we were shooting a very very
very humble poor towns near warsassad so
the experience of shooting the those
scenes there with the non-actors all of
those Moroccan characters were
non-actors that I trained with them and
then you are putting all these people
that has never seen a camera
and with Kate Blanchett to perform the
veterinarian and all that scenes that
were very intense where she's bleeding
and all those circumstances that I was
basically exposed to and exposing all
these actors and all the crew that we
went we need to achieve some
truthfulness about that
it was an extremely beautiful experience
you know challenging one but at the same
time was informing while I was doing
that
that I was in battle the language was
not we were helping to get what I needed
and it was just emotional things that
were able to get these guys to
understand what I was needed and once
they get into the motion it was amazing
but the language the words were useless
you know and that was super interesting
about it you know that it was just about
the emotional exercise or an images that
was triggered to them I remember there
was this guy that was supposedly the guy
that that that shot to Kate and he has
an amazing face like like a mysterious
guy but when he left he was with no two
then he was the most sweet almost little
cave but it was an old man and he
couldn't
cry and he supposedly has to cry in the
moment that the police arrived and and
and I have these incredible actress that
is him Abbas which is Palestinian and
she was helping me to translate to them
and suddenly him said something about
her mother
and apparently he never went to his
mother buried and in the moment that he
got that image and that memory and we
could penetrate that
boom
and a burst of crying and it was
truthful and then we start shooting and
then he couldn't stop so I said okay we
finished
what I'm saying it was very beautiful
how emotions are the universal language
you know
my modest battles
[Music]
this was a
powerfully written by guillermariaga I
developed with him for three years and
we talked endlessly about first of all
you know the different relations between
chivo which is the old man
whose family is the dogs he lives with
this family of dogs and the the the the
affection that he feels for them and
then you have these other characters
which in a way it's uh yeah it's a
family dog that's only turns to be a
great fighter and then you have other
guy which is basically you utility the
dogs are utilitarian to make money and
to to Savage them to destroy them you
know to use them as Warriors so yes
there is a different attachment to dogs
or animals as in real life happen the
difficulty was how I could make those
relations feel real so we have a lot of
months in advance
uh with a great trainer Larry Casanova
was cool and this guy he was an animal
lover and he trained all these animals
and he got these Street dogs to I put uh
Emilio trevoria the actor if she were to
really spend months with these guys in
order that when he walks the dogs were
really attached to him so you can see
that in the film and then obviously
or the other actor they were terrified
about dogs and these dogs were real doc
uh fight dogs you know that are super
difficult to control because they are
beasts that they can really bite you and
we have several events that were very
close to have an accident but they have
to overcome their fear I think every
film until Birdman I shot it
chronologically by the script because
for me was very important to be
understanding and having the
opportunities to maybe ship things
depending on how things were evolving
and to have the actors understanding
their own Journey
in a chronological order very radical
even when it was a nightmare for
producers and locations
but I think for me has been crucial to
to make a film in a chronological order
to be able to be growing with it
21 Grams
[Music]
how'd it go
not good Barbara in one ear out the
other
be patient all it takes is one sheep and
a thousand Jack come on afternoon
Reverend hey wolf you still having that
birthday party Wednesday my place Bubba
we were developing this script and uh
and there was this characteristic of the
role that we that Benicio del Toro play
and there was this religious relation
with faith and the way this character
was feeling and I felt that it was
very much into these possibilities of
shooting the south of of the United
States were sometimes religion can get
kind of very passionate and reductive in
some way that the relation is like I'm
good I'm gonna be good I'm bad I'm going
to be punished it was the first city in
Memphis that I touched I
embarked myself when I was 17 years in a
boat in a cargo boat and that was the
first city that I hid in the United
States through the Mississippi so anyway
a lot of things was concise that to make
my first American Film there so in a way
it was not planned but everything
started just to point to that direction
and I find myself in Memphis for six
months shooting this film and I remember
that even talking in English for me my
English is bad but at that time it was
much it was worse so for me to explain I
had to have surgery after because my
vocal cords I was using it differently
because when you speak English you have
to use differently your courts and the
US recipe so I got into a surgery at
that time you know for me the eyes and
the features of somebody is the story of
somebody it's the map is the emotional
map as powerful on any landscape you
know you can really see a lot of the
past a lot of the fears a lot of the joy
a lot of the complexity of human being
view pointed out in the right direction
with the right lighting there's a lot to
be revealed in one close-up
and there's nobody better
than operating the camera handheld which
is very difficult than Rodrigo Prieto
because he's a painter you know the the
problem with handheld cameras if it's
the overused it's already kind of too
overused like that so there's no reason
why to move that so you just get
nauseous about it so there's no reason
but Rodrigo in a way you know the every
movement of the actor every reason to be
moved he moved or every reason to be
stay he stay and we were shooting all
the time with 40 millimeters lenses
which was my favorite one at that time I
think Amores Perros and and that one I
think we shot it in 40 millimeters all
the time which for me kind of that's
where the vision is these films were
much more about
um the the the chances of improvisation
and things and again capturing with the
camera very natural very very very very
very raw
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
I think this film reflects a lot of
where I was at that time
as a person you know I was in a very low
kind of thing I was really seeing all
these immigration things going on in
Europe like all these African people
completely thrown out in the streets
where all these incredible Rich cultures
are not allowing them so as an immigrant
I always have been a symbol on that or
carne Arena the virtual reality thing
that I did about immigration crossing
the border is a theme that maybe because
I'm an immigrant is always very close so
I was observing kind of those kind of
things
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
and I was thinking about death I was
turning 50 years old
and I think that hit me so it's a film
that is very deep and personal
it's it's it's dark
I'm very proud of it when it came out it
was trash it was a disaster now it seems
that a lot of people say oh it's your
best film and I said well sometimes
films takes time to really you know
breathe for me the exercise here was I
have never made a film about one
character
and for me was terrifying to say now I
have just one character in one film a
narrative that is chronological and much
more conventional the Bardem character
the way was for me inspiring this father
trying to get care of other peoples and
help the immigrate and help their kids
and try to get through challenges and
been thinking about the others I start
playing with elements that were not real
we could see the motion of somebody how
they will look what are the elements
that can be manifested there so I start
playing with that
with that super Encounter of the father
at the end
and again it's because maybe my age
start inviting me to think about what
are you gonna live here
Bardo
is
in Mexico
some soda about it
I have never worked with this kind of
material that I that I that I closed my
eyes I went I recoup some things that
were emotionally uh important and there
was not necessarily true that's why the
false Chronicle of a handful of truth
actually things that I do not understand
so all these things for me was a way to
get some events or some personal
intimate things and some collective
memories of the thing that has made us
as Mexicans and bring in there and then
lying down and I said holy [ __ ] I don't
know what to do with this he said you
know there is a story with no story but
at the same time I think through fiction
in a way and through lie about them and
through really that you make it's a way
to heal it's a way to put light in the
darkness I lived in Mexico 35 36 years
let's say so it's my my city
it's it's my town
obviously 20 years 21 years has passed
so things has changed it's not the same
when I left but at the same time it's
like an like an all-new friend that you
know very well that you haven't seen in
years and you connect in one second so
that's very inspiring and especially the
sound of the city you know there's
something very beautiful about and
about the soundtrack of Mexico City and
the smells that's what I miss much more
when you live in United States you miss
that kakayang as we said you know the
relation between Mexico and United
States we our stories are completely
Blended right in the last 200 years but
it's a complicated one and it has been
French friendly but very contradictory
and very different with different sites
and there's a lot of open wounds let's
put it that way and that the
Mexican-American War as they call it
um it was 175 years ago and it was a
very traumatic experience because uh
where I shoot it is the Castillo
chapultepec the chapel castle that was
built by the Spanish in the 1600s and uh
you can tell the story of Mexico
basically there because later you know
that's where I think the American
militaries came in at the end of the war
and they took over and they they
slaughtered all these little kids and
then this mythology appears that the
Nino series which is kind of uh
might meet that has been built in The
Narrative of the heroic act they did but
everybody knows that it's not true but
in a way I want to approach this with
sense of humor of how ridiculous the
both sides of the story one the nine the
fact that it was actually an invasion
that they you know in that time they
took half of our country for 15 million
pesos and that's the way we told our
story in our side too is a little bit
ridiculous you know so in a way I'm
questioning the narratives of of both
sides with you more in kind of a kind of
a dream state and the execution was
extremely difficult I think more
difficult than the Revenant to close the
city at the center nobody has seen
downtown like that because this is the
Heart of the City all that sequence
where he is walking at night and there's
that the sun goes down in the middle of
the city with all these people because
there's 120 000 Disappearance in Mexico
in democracy in the last 10 years which
is kind of how you explain that by just
I wanted just to with an image what we
feel about how it feels to be
a possible victim of that with no reason
and the song goes down and all that part
that he's walking at night is a day for
night shooting which is a technique that
is used but we need to have a very
precise position of the sun and close
every street that has that kind of
moonlight sensation so everything was we
have to really analyze every day to
understand what is the light position to
get exactly in the top of the buildings
a little you know spread of that light
so again it it requires a lot of thought
in every show we shot it in soccer which
is exactly where the Aztec Empire was
there so all the pyramids were destroyed
and those pyramids are the stones of the
cathedral so in a way it was for me
important to be shooting those scenes in
the in the real locations you know
reinterpretation and actually even with
human too about things that has been
open wounds
uh would maybe not answer yet